principles for success an ultra
mini-series adventure in 30 minutes and
in eight episodes episode six your two
biggest barriers I can't tell you which
path in life is best for you because I
don't know how important it is for you
to achieve big goals relative to how
important it is for you to avoid the
pains required to get them this is the
courage I spoke of earlier and we each
have to feel these things out for
ourselves after my big mistake in
calling for a depression I had come to
one of life's forks in the road as we
all do if I made the choice to take a
normal job and play it safe I would have
ended up with a very different life than
the one I had but as long as I could pay
the rent put food on the table and
educate my kids
the only choice for me was to risk
crossing the jungle in pursuit of the
best life possible my big mistake
inventing on a depression gave me a
healthy fear of being wrong in other
words it gave me deep humility which was
exactly what I needed at the same time
it didn't stop me from aggressively
going after the things I wanted to
succeed I needed to see more than I
alone could see but standing in my way
of doing that were the two biggest
barriers everyone faces our ego and
blind spot barriers these barriers exist
because of how our brains work first
let's explore the ego barrier when I
refer to your ego barrier I'm talking
about the parts of your brain that
prevent you from acknowledging your
weaknesses objectively so that you can
figure out how to deal with them your
deepest seeded needs and fears reside in
areas of your brain that control your
emotions and are not accessible to your
higher-level conscious awareness and
because our need to be right can be more
important than our need to find out
what's true we like to believe our own
opinions without properly stress-testing
them we especially don't like to look at
our mistakes and we
mrs. we are instinctively prone to react
to explorations of them as though their
attacks we get angry even though it
would be more logical for us to be open
to feedback from others this leads to
our making inferior decisions learning
less and falling short of our potentials
the second is the blind spot barrier
everyone has blind spots the blind spot
barriers when a person believes he or
she can see everything but it's a simple
fact that no one alone can see a
complete picture of reality naturally
people can't appreciate what they can't
see just as we all have different ranges
for singing hearing pitch and seeing
colors we have different ranges for
seeing and understanding things for
example while some people are better at
seeing the big picture others excel at
see details some are linear thinkers and
others are more lateral while some are
creative but not reliable others are
reliable but not creative and so on
because of how our brains are wired
differently
everyone perceives the world around them
differently by doing what comes
naturally to us we fail to account for
our weaknesses and we crash either we
keep doing that or we change Aristotle
defined tragedy as a terrible outcome
arising from a person's fatal flaw a
flaw that had it been fixed would have
instead led to a wonderful outcome in my
opinion these two barriers of the main
impediments that get in the way of good
decision-making my fear of being wrong
gave me the radical open-mindedness I
needed and that changed everything
[Music]